what does it feel like to have your baby
born the book it feels great it's uh I
mean you know I when going through this
process you sort of go through
everything when you write a book When
anybody who just sits and just writes it
all down that you know eventually
somebody's going to read it's like it's
like if you just handed your diary to
people and they they give it to
everybody in the office and then
everybody they saw in the bus and then
every stranger they met you know forever
kind of thing
um so you go through all these emotions
when you're when you're writing it
insecurity and and everything but I
think that you have to get to the point
and I got this to the you know a little
while ago which is none of that stuff
bothers me anymore judgment doesn't
bother me
um you know criticism doesn't bother me
shame doesn't bother me none of that
stuff bothers me anymore and there would
not have been a way where I could have
released it if I was still bothered by
any of those things that I've been
bothered with for so many years of my
life let me get that you talk about
writing this book and I you know we have
a lot of questions about what was your
writing set up how did you write like
how did you sit down what did it look
like were you writing early in the
morning at night on weekends and what
was was this in the middle of your house
like what were you doing yeah so I would
um my I don't know if somebody wants to
do the math on this but I would um you
know five days a week I would wake up to
do the radio show at 3 50 a.m when I do
that I would finish that show be home by
10 30 I would come and do this show I
would come up to ET Canada for three
days three days a week and then even
doing all of that stuff with working
both shows I wrote 30 hours a week so I
would write until 10 o'clock every night
and then Saturday and Sunday I would get
up at 5 a.m and right until three
o'clock in the afternoon and I did that
for a full year when we went on vacation
we rented an RV last summer and just
drove around and Catherine drove the
whole way and I was sitting in the RV at
that table while we were moving and
driving writing chapters wow and then
the girls would go to bed and I would
make a fire
um at the campsite that we were at and I
would sit by by campfire with my laptop
on my on my lap just writing writing
chapters trying to make that what did it
do to the family you writing this book
in that moment uh I you know there's God
you know you know I just talked so much
about guilt in the book because there's
so many things that I've dealt with
guilt with
um uh and but I I really felt like
um this added to the guilt you know I
worked so hard and I'm and because I I
always want you know my kid to have you
know like cool stuff and I want her to
have a great life and you know I wanted
to experience wonderful things and I
just have this obsessiveness to work
very hard but in the back of my head I
have to keep reminding myself that if
working this hard and putting so much of
my body
sacrificing my body for work trading
hours for life you know to provide
something that's great my fear is that
one day my kid is going to wake up and
feel that she got ripped off because I
just wasn't there right where I was so
busy working hard that I wasn't there
for her and it was the same thing with
this story I knew that this would help
me immensely and I knew that if she ever
read it one day it would answer maybe
some of the questions that she has but
that two years writing this was you know
I was absent I was there when I could be
but I was really I was really busy and
then I felt bad because I'm like that's
another two years of weekends and
everything else and you did that with
your mom too right you went for a long
time not really my my mom didn't know I
wrote this and I Disappeared basically
for two years and she wondered what
happened you know she wondered why did
she feel like she needed to disappear
yeah because I needed to do this on my
own and I didn't want anybody's input
okay um because I think that when you
tell stories and you're dealing with
memory you know my memory of a certain
situation might be different than my
mom's it doesn't mean mine is right and
hers is wrong right or the reverse but
you can experience something and and you
both take something different away from
that and I didn't want anybody else's
side for things that meant a lot to me
one because I feared that maybe they
wouldn't mean as much anymore if
somebody was able to rationalize
something and I didn't want somebody to
take a great memory away from me before
I had a chance to share it I get that
now I always wondered when you talked
about you hadn't okay that makes sense
um listen this book has it all you talk
about everything you talk about abuse
you talk about Tourette's you talk about
self-harm body image workplace trauma
abusive relationships the death of your
hero you talk about all of it
what was the most difficult to write and
what took you the longest
you know the interesting thing is that
the things that hurt the most were the
easiest to write
really yeah yeah because I had never
told anybody those stories but I had it
all inside I would the only person I
ever talked about to any of that stuff
was myself right I would only confide in
myself and so I knew exactly I'd been
able to sort of put pieces together over
the years
um and and you know and sort of you know
like I don't hurt myself anymore but I
did for a very long time I did for half
my life
you know I did
um and it wasn't because I hated myself
and it wasn't because I thought I was a
bad person
um but it was because when you don't
feel like things fit oftentimes people
do things
to make things fit and I didn't know
what normal felt like but I knew that in
those moments when I was hurting myself
that that I would feel normal right
so then I have to ask you this because
there will be people watching this who
can who can identify with what you're
saying about hurting themselves so I
think it's an important question to ask
when did you know and how did you stop
um when did I know okay I'll tell you
hurting myself was the was the same
thing with as it was with you know when
I was taking diet pills
um when I almost destroyed my liver on
with diet pills is I knew it was wrong
right right away because I kept it a
secret right right right and the one
thing I know about addicts my my dad was
an alcoholic and he was sober for the
vast majority of my life I never drank
but I was introduced to addicts very
early on in my life because he was a
counselor and the one thing that I
learned about addicts is one they're
great people but addicts lie
and all addicts lie and you you
rationalize to yourself and you lie to
the people you love yes and I knew that
it was a problem when I was lying and I
would lie about scars and I would lie
about my weight and I would lie about
all of this stuff
um even with even with Tourette's if
anybody ever asked you know what was
going on if they ever noticed me
twitching or whatever I would lie about
that and so when you but I wasn't lying
just to them I was lying to myself right
and I think that what happens when
somebody feels broken when somebody
um you know when when somebody doesn't
sort of know where their place is in in
the world I think that you just keep
it's like grief you keep waiting for the
day that you wake up and it's no longer
there right and I think that the trick
is what worked for me anyway was I had
to stop waiting for it to go away and I
had to make space for it and take it
with me and and that goes with with with
self-harm and it goes with addiction and
it goes with the death of my dad is that
it was never going to go away and I just
had to learn to live with it and it's a
part of me and I couldn't move forward
if I was still hiding and I couldn't
move forward if I was still lying doing
it yeah and I and so I had to make I had
to make space for and it's and it's with
me it's I'm not over anything right like
I the first line in the book is that it
never gets better it just gets easier
yeah and I think that that's and I've
heard a lot of things a lot over the
years I've heard you say that line
before yeah and now it makes sense